though it's a toss-up personally i would
feel more at risk hanging out one-on-one
with amber hurd than i would if i had to
take a meeting with harvey weinstein
oh that took a turn okay
sorry this is your answer okay so
personally i would feel more at risk
hanging out one-on-one with amber heard
than i would
if i had to take a meeting with
harvey weinstein i'm going to say that
you
are gonna say yes to that
yes
you would be more at risk hanging out
with i wouldn't i would because i'm not
harvey's type as far as i can tell
i'm not in his industry there's not much
he can do to me yeah amber heard she
could
boil my rabbit i mean that woman she
could destroy uh truly could destroy a
man's life yeah now did i get yours
right so
i don't feel at risk with either one i
think they would be at risk to be quite
honest so i don't know how to
it's a margin call so i have to say who
would i be more at risk with amber heard
or harvey weinstein or
gosh neither one of them
they'd both be in danger they would be
endangered they should be the ones they
would be unreal so it's the question are
you at risk the answer is just no yeah
no no never okay that's good so we both
got it right okay okay okay
that's funny that i would but certainly
you know you think i guess now though if
i had a meeting with harvey weinstein
would be separated by you know steel
bars so it'd probably probably be okay
now too gosh but you wouldn't want that
energy no
i don't need that sometimes i wish they
would have had me take that meeting i
think i cancelled on it and i was just
like no did you did you get an um yeah
like like they always want their like
the agency was always like we need to
have you meet this guy and i was like i
think i cancelled once and then it had
to get reset up um but
i have this and i wish they would have i
have this vision of you meeting with
harvey weinstein and then you know
smash cut weinstein is just
defenestrated out of the beverly hills
hotel or something yeah
i mean
i never understood the whole me too
thing because i was just like you could
just say no you just get up and walk out
he shows up in his bathrobe you say no
thanks buster yeah just say no
no is a complete sentence
oh that's a good line yeah okay fine i
stole it from tyler but uh that's good
well just say no was from nancy reagan
but they're both good lines yes